je suis là pour répondre à toutes les
questions
[Musique]
alors ce nouveau spectacle qui s'appelle
d'ailleurs qui parle de la foi qui parle
de la paternité de l'hyperslicitation
des réseaux sociaux mais j'aborde des
sujets que j'ai rarement abordé comme la
religion la mort avec beaucoup de comics
qui sont des sujets plutôt tragiques
quoi bonjour je m'appelle Kadi et
bonjour je m'appelle Pharrell et du coup
Gad Elmaleh on voulait de te demander ça
t'a fait quoi de rencontrer la famille
royale à Monaco et tout ça a dû être
dingue genre
[Musique]
super question de caddie et Pharrell
déjà on va parler de vos prénoms les
gars franchement ils sont stylés je sais
pas d'où vous les avez sortis je parle
en tout cas de la rencontre de ma mère
avec la famille à Monaco parce que c'est
un moment que moi je prends beaucoup de
plaisir à jouer et que je trouve très
très drôle c'est là où j'avais des plus
gros rire tous les soirs c'est un moment
qui est assez tendre aussi parce que je
le fais avec beaucoup de bienveillance
aussi
mais je me moque plus de nous et du
syndrome du blédard que je décris dans
le
dans le spectacle donc les gars je vous
laisse regarder le spectacle et vous me
direz ce que vous pensez de cette grande
rencontre entre ma mère et le Prince de
Monaco bonjour Alors je m'appelle Léane
et moi c'est capucine et on se demandait
comment vous aviez eu l'idée de faire un
nouveau spectacle moi j'ai trois étapes
de travail tout le temps la première
c'est ce que j'appelle l'Impuls je vais
dans un taxi le gars va me dire un truc
et je ne sais pas pourquoi ça c'est je
sais qu'il y a quelque chose à faire
c'est pas immédiatement comique mais je
sais qu'il y a quelque chose à faire la
deuxième étape c'est de prendre toutes
ces notes que j'ai prises qui étaient
des trucs d'un pulse et les ranger par
famille et par thème et bizarrement il y
a toujours quelque chose qui se dessine
puisque c'est la même personne qui écrit
et la troisième étape c'est la plus
importante c'est d'aller dans les
comédies clubs pour roder roder rôder
travailler expérimenter et prouver les
vannes moi c'est une riche Nelson j'ai
26 ans la question que j'aimerais poser
à Gad Elmaleh qu'est-ce qu'il fait à
chaque fois
lorsqu'il veut monter sur scène c'est
est-ce qu'il a du est-ce qu'il a du trac
ou bien on va dire que le trac il est
différent mais c'est un peu déplacé et
il est il est moins intense et il est
pour d'autres raisons qu'avant par
exemple j'ai des petits trucs quoi je
j'arrive jamais maintenant tôt au
théâtre j'ai envie d'arriver 20 minutes
avant le show 15 minutes avant le chaud
je m'habille je marche boum je vais sur
scène et ça ça m'empêche d'avoir le trac
salut gad El Valais est-ce que par
rapport à l'anecdote de la honte du sac
en plastique je veux savoir est-ce que
c'est c'est la seule honte qui s'est
passé ou pas voilà alors cette question
fait référence à la vidéo qu'on a faite
avec McFly et Carlito sur les anecdotes
je crois que les moments les plus
difficiles dans la vie d'un jeune acteur
c'est surtout les castings quand tu te
présentes à un casting tu te tapes des
petits tâches sous Mac quoi mais ça
aussi ça m'a servi et ça aussi ça aide
pour après avoir confiance salut Gad moi
c'est Olivia je voulais savoir dans
combien de pays est-ce que tu et combien
et quels sont les langues que tu parles
je suis né au Maroc à Casablanca j'ai
été élevé au Maroc et très tôt je suis
parti au Canada ensuite je suis venu en
France ensuite je suis allé aux
États-Unis je parle je veux dire
couramment en français anglais
hébreu et arabe voilà c'est quatre
langues que je parle je suis en train
d'apprendre l'italien donc bientôt je
parlerai cinq ans salut je m'appelle
Farès j'ai 27 ans et ma question pour
Gad c'est est-ce que tu as prévu comme
les grands autres comédiens à Paris de
ouvrir ton Comedy Club et de faire
émerger des nouveaux talents on va dire
que si c'est une dynamique à plusieurs
je le ferai mais pas mais pas tout seul
quoi je suis pas très bon en ce qui
concerne la gestion d'un lieu je sais
pas très bien faire les hot-dogs voilà
non mais plus sérieusement
salut gars je m'appelle Chiara j'ai 21
ans et ma petite question c'est moi j'ai
entendu dire que pour toi ta mère c'est
la personne la plus drôle de la terre et
c'est pour savoir si pour tes offices
toi aussi tu aimes mec le plus drôle de
la terre je crois que pour pour un de
mes fils je suis le mec le plus droit
le plus grand qui a énormément d'humour
qui est très pinçant rire qui capte tout
et qui est plus dans l'échange avec moi
c'est normal c'est son âge et voilà il a
et puis il a un humour très très fin
mais le petit je peux le dire de manière
avec beaucoup de fierté il est fan c'est
juste je le fais rire et il aime que je
le fasse rire et c'est et ça ça me
bouleverse donc mais j'espère pour les
deux oui je vais le mettre le plus drôle
au monde et pour reprendre ce que je
disais sur ma maman elle elle le fait
pas exprès salut Gad c'est Romain
j'avais une question pour toi je voulais
savoir qui était le spectateur qui t'a
le plus marqué c'est celui qui s'endort
au premier rang
et
que tu essayes de réveiller bonjour je
m'appelle Étienne et ma question serait
quel est votre plus grand objectif
maintenant que vous accompli autant de
choses dans votre vie waouh
Étienne ça c'est une grande question il
y a quelques années mes objectifs
c'était plus haut plus fort plus grand
après 50 ans le challenge le plus
intérieur vraiment je dis pas ça pour
faire Zama est-ce que le spectacle de la
maturité oui bonjour Gad moi je
m'appelle Jeanne et ma question c'est
après tous ces années de spectacle de
comédie qu'est-ce que tu dirais à ton
ancien toi quand tu étais jeune
mon ancien moi je lui épargnerais en
tout cas des
égarements mais en même temps c'est
comme ça qu'on apprend je dirais juste
au petit moi je dirais juste protège-toi
parce qu'on n'est jamais prêt finalement
à des choses qui humainement dans le
métier nous heurte je m'appelle Charles
et j'aimerais te poser une question Gad
quels sont tes projets futurs maintenant
que la tournée et enfin bouclée ce qui
reste quand même ma priorité c'est la
scène j'ai j'ai mis des années avant
d'assumer cette réponse donc j'écris mon
nouveau spectacle voilà pour l'instant
c'est d'ailleurs sur Canal+ et
uniquement sur Canal+ et après il y aura
encore de la scène un nouveau spectacle
voilà
[Musique]